6 24 here on a thursday morning it is
earth day and living here in the desert
we certainly know we cannot take our
water for granted and we've seen a lot
of stories in the news recently
about trying to protect our shrinking
supply yeah a federal water shortage
could be declared now for the southwest
that of course would include us here in
nevada
sheri is here now with a look at a
program that actually pays you to save
water good morning jerry good morning
wasting water is the biggest mistake
that we can make
and grassy green lawns have been
targeted as the greatest source of water
waste
in southern nevada especially if the
only time you step on it
is to mow it so why not take some cash
to trade it
for something that's more desert
friendly
we use more water outdoors to keep our
lawns lush and plants blooming
than we do indoors to keep our homes and
ourselves clean
the agency that manages our water supply
says it's a waste of the community's
most critical resource
as we try to avoid a thirsty future
because we are the driest
city in the driest state in the nation
anything that grows outside has to be
irrigated
and grass is one of the most water
intensive landscapes
that we can have here
when the sprinklers come on that water
gets used once
unlike the water indoors which gets
recaptured treated and used again
cutting out unnecessary grass saves
water and helps bank valuable reserves
says bronson mack with the southern
nevada water authority if you aren't
playing on that grass picnicking on that
grass
that's grass that you should really be
thinking about replacing
at the beginning signs of drought 20
years ago
snwa asked residents nicely to start
saving water where they could
but as the population boomed and the
long dry period
has taken an extreme toll on withering
lake mead
conserving has become the cornerstone of
ensuring we'll have water when we need
it
today's message hits the public much
harder
reality check they're big fines if you
don't change a watering clock
enforcing strict seasonal watering
schedules is working
and paying homeowners and commercial
properties to remove
non-functional grass has reached a
successful milestone
this community has actually now removed
enough grass
that we could stretch an 18-inch wide
strip of sod around the full
circumference of the
earth that's a considerable amount of
grass that we've removed so far
that's right 18 inches of turf wrapped
around the globe
adds up to more than 197 million square
feet
which is more than 4500 square acres
equal to more than 3 400 football
fields or over 110
allegiant stadiums full of grass that
saves about 10 billion gallons of water
every year
and the water authority says there's
more grass to get rid of
that's about half of all the
non-functional turf that's out there in
our community
so we still have about another 5 000
acres that we need to replace with water
smart landscaping
the rebate program pays a hefty three
dollars for every square foot of grass
removed
in your yard or commercial property when
you trade for more efficient
adaptable landscaping that's water smart
like the desert environment we live in
and you may have heard there is proposed
legislation now to ban all existing
decorative grass by the end of 2026 but
snwa
says that would not affect single-family
residences
only commercial properties streetscapes
medians and hoa
areas with unused grass so there's still
time to cash in
on your grass while it's your idea and
we have that link to snwa with the page
of
fill out the rebate form that's on our
website eightnewsnow.com
i've done it myself i've done my
backyard at the end of the story that
was actually
my backyard with the lounge chairs i did
it two springs ago
it's quite a process and i do have to
say you have to know what you want
uh there are a list of of contractors
that
snwa does provide not recommend but
provide
and you call you need to get estimates
there's a process that you have to go
through so just know that you have to
plan for it and but that rebate check
helps pay for the conversion because it
does cost a little bit of money to do
that it's not always that cheap
yeah it's a good incentive well your
backyard turned out great sherry they
did a good job
it worked out